[Music]
one of the first vulnerabilities that
developers need to learn about is sql
injection we learned about sql injection
in 1998 christmas day when jeff
forestall first coined the term in frack
magazine sql injection now as a
developer we have to be careful about
this problem this problem happens when
you use string building to assemble a
database query in your code instead you
should use
parameterized queries you should also do
very strict validation of all input and
when you can't parameterize a variable
be careful make sure you constrain that
input to letters and numbers only no
spaces or punctuation and last you want
to configure your database using the
principle of least privilege
parameterize queries that's the most
important part but these other defenses
will help ensure your app is immune to
sql injection